let's see if we can write 59.2% if we
can write this as a decimal
well 59.2% this literally means 59.2 per
cent which literally means 59.2 per 100
which literally means 59.2 per 100 which
is the same thing as fifty nine point
two divided by 100 and if we were to
divide 59.2 by 100 what do we get so
this is the same thing as fifty nine
point two divided by 100 so if we if we
were to take fifty nine point two if we
wanted to divide it by ten we would move
the decimal over to the left once we
would get five point nine two but we
want to divide it by 100 so we move the
decimal over to the left again we're
dividing by ten once and then we're
dividing by ten again divided by ten
twice you're essentially dividing by 100
so you move the decimal to the left
twice you get 0.592 and we'll just put a
zero out here just to clarify things and
we're done we've written 59.2% as a
decimal we essentially just divided this
by a hundred which is dividing by 10
twice moving the decimal once to the
left and then another time or since
we're dividing by 100 moving the decimal
twice to the left and we get zero point
five nine two